Kanye West led a tribute to Kobe Bryant
Sunday night during one of his famous
Sunday services
Kim kardashian-west shared several
moments from the event
in one video Kanye's saying about the
moment he learned the shocking news of
Brian's death
[Music]
the service also featured performances
by chance the rapper in Kirk Franklin
[Music]
earlier that day Kim posted an emotional
tribute to the victims families of the
tragic accident she wrote quote I am
praying for the Bryan family at the
Altobelli family and the families of all
who perished in this unthinkable tragedy
rest in peace legend the tributes came
on the heels of the Grammy Awards where
more of Kanye and Kim Spears paid their
respects to the late great Laker Kobe
Bryant was was one of the greatest that
ever played the game he came from high
school went straight to the pros
he won championships with number eight
championships with number 24 it's just
amazing and and to have him gone and
took his little daughter with him it's
just what's sad it's heartbreaking like
being here like you know it's the
Grammys but because we're at Staples
Center it's sad like I feel really you
feel the energy and it's heartbreaking
and he was an idol god I mean I don't
know how to put it I I thought it was
fake because how can you not it really
makes you think about how a lot of
things I don't know it's really hard to
talk about it I just can't stop crying
and even to think of it and Kobe was
such a great man living oz said it best
not only was he a legend in sports but
he was a legend as a man as a father and
just a great role model and it's a it's
a very sad tragic day and and
bittersweet for all of us here at the
Grammys